[Music]
okay so I want to talk to you today
about the shinies server pro
architecture and give you a bit of a
feel for how things were organized how
things are run with in Chinese server
server Pro alright so first of all shiny
server Pro is kind of an extended as an
extension of the open-source Chinese
server package which we generally just
called Chinese server and so basically
you can view Pro as kind of enhancements
and new sets of features that add on to
the open source package so when you talk
about the architecture of Pro or open
source it probably makes sense to start
with a discussion about the open source
Chinese server and then we can kind of
grow from there into what Pro adds on to
that but you know I mention here a
couple of the features that are often
most compelling for pro so you know we
do user authentication with whether
that's LDAP or Active Directory and then
also we do application scaling across
multiple processes for a single
application which is so ok so to go kind
of all the way down the hole we get down
into the shiny package and I suspect
that most of you are familiar with shiny
but basically shiny is as you know in
our package but just what's important to
realize is the Chinese speaks WebSocket
and so what that means is that any
browser that's compatible with websites
can connect directly to a shiny process
and do you know the communications there
back and forth between those two
entities so that's great and you
probably noticed this when you're
developing applications locally so if
you're using our studio for instance and
you press run app you're gonna get a
little viewer that viewer is
communicating directly to your art
process or you know if you open a
browser you're communicating directly
with our process and there's no shiny
server intermediary between those two
and that's because Chinese speaks web
sockets so innovating so it is possible
to open a direct connection from a
browser into the shiny process
so that's great but there are a couple
limitations on this first of all as I
mentioned that only works for browsers
that can communicate over WebSockets and
so that rules out Internet Explorer 8
and 9 and some older versions of Firefox
and Chrome and things like that
the other problem is that the shiny
process has to be running at the moment
you try to open a connection to it and
so that can be a little complicated in
that if you have an organization maybe
you have you know hundreds of training
applications that you've developed in
any given time maybe you know the
handful of them are actually being used
and interacted with the problem is here
that you know in order to communicate
shiny would have to be running all of
like you would have to be running one
process for each of those applications
all the time around the clock and that
creates a lot of problems in terms of
resource utilization if you're trying to
run these one hundreds or even thousands
of processes all the time even though
many of them are may not be used you
know but you know a few minutes a day so
so there are couple limitations to just
running shiny on the bare metal but but
it is possible so shiny server sets out
to accomplish a few goals the the couple
that are that are interesting for this
discussion are first of all it should
start and stop shiny processes on demand
and as as needed and also it should
translate non WebSocket traffic into
WebSocket traffic that's fine you can
understand and then finally it can it
can also map different URLs to
particular applications so if you were
just a run an army of shiny processes on
your bare machine all of those would
have to run on different ports and so
your users would need to enter a port
number and order to get to an
application and it would be you know a
little sloppy
and so shiny server offers a kind of a
cleaner more convenient way to be able
to navigate between the different
applications and we do that by offering
a few different hosting modes so you
could just post one application you
could allow users to miss their own
applications or you could host an entire
directory of applications and you can do
these at different URLs of spaces so it
just allows you to kind of more
meaningfully manage you know many shiny
applications and so a couple of these to
kind of revisit so starting a sparkling
shiny processes
so again this is you know if you're
running this my evilly you would need to
be running that training process all the
time but because you're running a
Chinese service like this long long
running you know always on Damen what
that means is that when a user goes to
connect into the training process if
it's not running now Chinese server can
kind of hold that request for a second
while it goes to start the training
process and then once the signing
training process is ready it can let the
traffic through into that process so you
can kind of broker and manage the
communications between applications that
may or may not be running at the moment
they're requested and then also if it
notices that all the users have left and
that that applications been idle for
some configurable at the time then it
can go ahead and reap those processes to
free up some more resources for other
applications and again like I mentioned
older versions of Internet Explorer are
not going to be able to handle
WebSockets natively and so shiny server
uses a library called sock giants which
basically allows you to work as if you
were working with WebSockets but it will
kind of gracefully fall back into other
protocols as needed and that's that's
actually really important even if you're
not planning to support older versions
of Internet Explorer because many
networks if you're using the older
network equipment that was designed
before WebSockets you know gained
popularity then you'll actually end up
in a situation where they may be
dropping or blocking WebSocket traffic
and we see this quite a bit especially
in the universities and academic
settings they for some reason tend to
have network equipment that isn't
something with WebSockets so you you can
kind of end up in the situation where
you know even if you're using all the
latest and greatest technology there may
be some router between you and your
client that is gonna interrupt your web
socket traffic and so it's nice to have
a technology that will allow you to fall
back to something that is supported if
needed so so that that ends up being a
pretty important feature okay and then
as we already discussed being able to
map URLs to two different applications
okay so kind of an overview of the
architecture you can envision it looking
something like this so you have a
variety of users over here and if you
can see the mouse that's read up in here
you have your variety of users over here
you know which which could
handful or you know we run servers where
there are hundreds of concurrent
connections from different users around
the world but they're all opening
connections into your shiny server
instance which again is kind of this
always-on server process that's running
as a daemon on your new server and then
it's going to open and close these or
start and stop these shiny applications
and kind of proxy the traffic as it goes
through from users browsers into the
shiny applications and so what this
typically looks like just to give you a
feel if you're going to get down to the
network level the first request of
course is just for kind of the review RL
of some application Chinese server would
go ahead and inspect is that application
already online so let's say it max you
know some URL to app one so it would go
through and state is have one already
online if it is it'll proxy to traffic
through if it's not it'll start up on
and then approximately traffic through
and then I just kind of continue to keep
these channels open between the user and
the application so what what this looks
like at a network level the first
request is going to be for kind of the
root URL of that application and then
that's gonna return some HTML that you
know it's gonna kind of point the
browser to different static assets but
may be of relevance the CSS files and
JavaScript files and things like that
and so it'll you know open up more
connections for all of those files and
then eventually it'll actually open the
web socket or web socket like connection
that will be persistent between that
browser in that shiny application and
that's kind of how shiny the shiny
metric works is via that that website go
to that website like channel that allows
the user and the shiny I think the shiny
process to communicate back and forth
for as long as that connection is open
so this is kind of hopefully gives you a
feel for